إنه أول دواء في فئته
تمت الموافقة عليه لمرضى الصداع النصفي ويمكن للكثيرين
أخيرًا الحصول على دواء
يناسبهم أعلنت إدارة الغذاء والدواء الأمريكية
الموافقة على إخوانه اليابان
هذا الأسبوع وهو مخصص للعلاج
الحاد للصداع النصفي الذي يستطيع الشخص البالغ أن يفعله.
أخذ أو لا يستجيب للأدوية الحالية
في السوق في دراسة
نُشرت الشهر الماضي ، كان أكثر من 19 في
المائة من الأشخاص الذين تناولوا العقار خاليين من
الألم في غضون ساعتين ، وحوالي 40 في
المائة تعافوا من
الأعراض المنهكة مثل
حساسية الضوء والضوضاء أكثر من غيرهم
فئة من العقاقير الموصوفة بشكل شائع للصداع النصفي تعمل عن طريق
تضييق الأوعية الدموية حول
الدماغ لذا فهي ليست آمنة لأولئك
المعرضين لخطر الإصابة بأمراض القلب والأوعية الدموية أو السكتة الدماغية.
خمس نساء وواحد من كل
ستة عشر رجلاً يعانون من الحالة
الصحية لهذا اليوم أنا ميريديث
وود